I’m going to try and make it through an
episode about lightning without making a single
electricity pun.
I know, shocking.
Welp, I tried.
Hey there, Julian here for DNews.
Odds are at some point in your life you’ve
seen a thunderstorm but you’ve probably
never taken part in one.
The chances of being hit by lightning in the
US in a given year are about 1 in a million,
so unless you’re one of the few who has
been singled out by Zeus, you’ll never know
what it’s like to have a stormcloud personally
bully you.
Lucky for you, I can tell you all about it,
in agonizing detail.
Now of course on DNews we've talked about lightening in past in the past
and how it works but to jolt your memory I'll just re-explain that
The conventional wisdom on lightning is it’s
caused when a static charge builds up in a
cloud.
It’s still debated how exactly, but the
simplest explanation is ice descending from
the top of the cloud strips electrons from
water droplets ascending from the bottom,
and after a while there’s a massive negative
charge at the base.
The negati ve charge is so strong it actually
repels electrons on earth, pushing them down
into the ground, and the surface of the earth
becomes positively charged.
Like teenage lovebirds, opposites attract,
and eventually the air, which serves as the
stern parents in this analogy, can’t keep
the charges apart.
They overcome the insulative properties of
the air, and a stream of electrons shoots
down to the ground and sparks fly.
Isn’t science romantic?
But if someone’s in the middle, they’re
going to get hurt.
Delivering up to a billion volts and billions
of watts, a bolt of lightning can be fatal,
and 10 percent of the time it is.
There are a few different ways a jolt from
the heavens can finish you off.
A number of your bodily systems rely on an
electrical rhythm, and a zap from God’s
shock collar can throw those out of whack.
One of the leading causes of death is cardiac
arrest, though respiratory arrest and seizures
aren’t uncommon either.
Even if your brain doesn’t misfire, it can
still be cooked by the intense heat of the
bolt.
If you’re not killed, that same heat will
probably leave third degree burns at the points
the lightning entered and exited your body.
It could set your hair and clothes on fire.
And any metal you’re wearing like necklaces
or belt buckles will also become superheated,
leaving burns.
Lightning also heats the air around you, up
to 20,000 degrees celsius, or over three times
hotter than the surface of the sun.
That rapid heating causes the air to expand.
If you’re farther away, you would hear it
as a sound wave, aka a crack of thunder.
But if you’re standing in the middle of
it, that expansion is actually a shock wave.
It can send you flying, burst your eardrums,
tear your clothes to shreds, and literally
knock your shoes off.
Yes, apparently being struck by lightning
is excruciatingly painful with a touch of
slapstick comedy.
Effects of being struck by lightning can linger
long after the storm has passed, and unless
you’re Tony Cicoria, who got a bolt to the
face and became a piano virtuoso, usually
they’re not superpowers.
Chronic pain, headaches, personality change,
difficulty concentrating, and muscle twitches
are just a few of the long term effects reported
by lightning strike victims.
Not to mention the physical scars, which in
the case of Lichtenberg figures, actually
resemble lightning itself.
On the plus side, that’s about a million
times more badass than getting a barbed wire
tattoo.
But did you know that lightning can also happen
INSIDE A VOLCANO?
We have more about how lightning forms and
how the heck this volcano lightning happens
here.
Statistically one of you watching has been
struck by lightning.
If you have or know someone who has, tell
us about it!